[Music]
let's talk about the lone ranger this
movie isn't coming out for a little bit
yet but highly anticipated
film and they just uh released the
trailer and it's getting an incredible
amount of buzz you've got to be excited
about this i am excited i mean i
remember the night before the trailer uh
somebody called me i think it was from
bruckheimer's office and they were like
uh you excited the trailer comes out
tonight i was like already wait no no
i'm not ready for this like no no no no
we gotta like let's take it let's take a
break for a second and it's it's here so
like they're going to listen to you on
that yeah
no no no no i'm not ready let's let's
change the schedule you co-star in this
movie uh with johnny depp yep got to be
pretty amazing yeah that was i mean just
incredible experience getting to work
with that guy and it was
yeah he's a he's a character he's he's
amazing he's every bit as cool as you
don't think it's possible for him to be
that just blew my mind what you just
said
i hope it makes sense i like that yeah
it makes sense but it's uh you when you
when you first met him were you nervous
when you first met johnny depp no i i
would say startled like i wasn't i
wasn't nervous i was startled we were we
were sitting in a table he was naked
he jumped out would have been easier he
was naked and holding a gun
he jumped out of a cabinet
we were actually doing a table read for
the script uh in a office building just
uh there was no cameras around there was
no people around it was just everyone in
the movies sitting there and i was
sitting there kind of like looking over
my script highlighting my lines getting
ready for the table reading someone
attacked and goes oh army this is johnny
and i turn around and he was wearing the
full get up like the full face
he's tonto he's tonto and he's wearing
the full crazy makeup face paint and all
that so they go army this is johnny i
should go oh hey sorry something in my
throat nice to meet you man
very startling was he in character or do
you behave normally no he behaved
normally he just didn't look normal yeah
let's show the trailer let's just show
the trailer and then we'll we'll talk
more about the film let's look at this
trailer uh from the lone ranger
[Music]
[Music]
why am i covered in dirt
i buried you
[Music]
why am i a lie
people think you are dead
better to stay that way
you only wear masks
come a time when good man must wear
masks
all right
let's do this
[Applause]
that's cool
i i'm stunned by
that shot where you're on this uh giant
structure yeah uh is that cgi no that's
real how well that was crazy yeah that
is a point called dead horse point and
you know if anything in nature is named
after an animal it's pretty intense and
a dead animal specifically never a good
sign not a good no one says let's go
have a hamburger at dead horse point
right
you couldn't if you wanted to because
you can't even get water on dead horse
point but uh i mean obviously it's not
that sort of cylindrical and tall it's
more of a beaut but we shot on the edge
of it and they built this
wooden structure that
i got to the bottom of it and i looked
up and i remember grabbing one of the
beams and just kind of pushing it
remember like this is moving a little
bit like this isn't this doesn't feel
very solid and they're like yeah yeah so
what you're going to do there's actually
a carabiner up there yeah so go up there
and clip yourself in i was like no one's
going up there they're like we can't
really put two people on it i was like
they probably weren't that worried about
losing you because i thought you had a
twin
probably
well we got another one
[Applause]